what is going on everybody thanks for
stopping by the channel today I'm Warren
Thompson and San Diego Comic-Con is
right around the corner the biggest
event of the year for us pop culture
fans specifically us superhero and
Marvel fans San Diego ComicCon or sdcc
is typically where all of the big
reveals happen fans wait all year for
sdcc and fight for tickets and hotel
rooms and it's just a huge Awesome event
and it looks like this year is going to
be no different for Marvel Studios last
year Marvel Studios shocked Us by
revealing phase five but also some parts
of phase six including two new Avengers
movies now to this day we still wonder
if that was the actual plan the names
for the two Avengers films got leaked
the day before Marvel's Hall h panel
revealing that the titles were indeed
Avengers the King Dynasty and Avengers
secret War so we wonder if it was
actually Marvel studios's plan to reveal
these Avengers films and anything with
phasee 6 or since the titles got leaked
did they just decide to go ahead and say
okay let's just kind of tell them then
they already know let's reveal some of
Phase 6 regardless of whatever the
reason was we were happy and we're super
excited and ready for this year's San
Diego ComiCon now San Diego ComiCon is
from Wednesday July 19th through Sunday
July 23rd with the Marvel Hall h panel
taking place on July 22nd which is a
Saturday and Marvel fans are wondering
what exactly should they be expecting
from Marvel Studios and one of the
biggest things that you can expect is
some new trailers specifically our first
full trailer for Loki season 2 up till
this point we've only got clips of Loki
season 2 Loki season 2 has not had its
own dedicated official trailer we've had
Disney plus trailers we've had Marvel
Disney plus upcoming show trailers which
included Loki footage however we haven't
had a specific Ally dedicated Loki
season 2 trailer yet but all signs point
to it being released at San Diego
ComicCon and here's why we expect it
Loki season 2 is not going to be the
only trailer released at San Diego
Comic-Con yesterday The Insider account
came we get some toast revealed that we
are going to be getting the first
trailer for The Echo series at San Diego
ComiCon and here's what's really
interesting about this the echo series
comes out after the Loki series Echo is
coming out November 29th and what's
interesting about Ekko is that they're
going to release the entire series all
of its episode on this day all at once
binge style this was already officially
confirmed and announced by Disney and
Marvel Studios themselves so this is
very different than what Disney and
Marvel have done in the past with their
other Disney Plus shows Loki however has
an October 6th release date and the
episodes will not be dropping all at
once they will be released each week one
episode per week so the fact that the
Insiders are stating we are going to get
an Echo trailer means that we also
should be getting a Loki season 2 full
dedicated official trailer since it
comes out before the echo series it's
the next project to come out that we
don't have a trailer yet for we have a
trailer for secret Invasion we have a
trailer for the Marvels but none for
Loki and none for Ekko which are the two
upcoming series and in fact the Marvels
releases after Loki season 2 and we've
already gotten our teaser trailer for
the Marvels so that does mean we should
be getting the Loki season 2 trailer at
San Diego ComicCon however the only
thing that could possibly prevent this
is all of the stuff happening right now
with Jonathan Majors it really should
not delay anything the only thing that
could delay it is the fact that when the
trailer comes out people are going to
see Jonathan majors and right now Marvel
Studios might not want that however we
have heard that Marvel Studios has done
some re-shoot for Loki we've also heard
that the end of Loki season 2 will tell
us the fate of Jonathan majors according
to Insider Alex P Marvel Studios has
decided what they want to do with
Jonathan majors and that is revealed at
the end of Loki season 2 and they can't
just cut Kang out of Loki season 2 he is
going to be a huge part of the entire
show just like he was in the first so
Jonathan Majors is going to appear in
Loki season 2 so putting off the trailer
doesn't really make sense but again the
only reason they would do that is
because of the association with Jonathan
Majors but besides that since we're
getting the Echo trailer we should be
getting the Loki season 2 trailer and
it's actually quite an important trailer
it's extremely important for the entire
Multiverse storyline Loki season 2 is
going to dive deep into the variance of
he who remains or King the Conqueror
we're also going to dive into the
previous multiversal war and the new
multiversal war so it's a project that
Marvel Studios really cannot delay or
put off but here's the good news the
promos that have already gone out for
Loki season 2 including promotional art
don't really include King the footage
that that we've gotten so far doesn't
really include King and neither do the
pictures so they could just release a
trailer that doesn't really show much of
king or he who remains or Victor timely
as the post credit scene for Ant-Man and
the was quantum Mania showed us so as of
right now we are planning for this
trailer and of course like I mentioned
we are getting the Echo trailer as well
which hopefully gives us glimpses of
Kingpin since he is going to be the main
villain of the show and we've heard that
we are going to see kind of flashbacks
of Maya Lopez rising to the rank in the
tracksuit Mafia with Kingpin being her
mentor and personally training her so
I'm excited to see what the trailer
shows us I'm also excited to see if
Daredevil is going to be in the trailer
we know he's going to be in the show and
he's going to play a pretty decent role
so hopefully we see Matt Murdoch return
in the trailer there is also the
possibility not the confirmation of but
the possibility that we could be getting
the full the Marvel's trailer this will
be about 4 months before the movie comes
out and that is about the the time frame
when Marvel Studios sometimes decides to
release full trailers for movies they do
vary but that is right around a good
time because as we know Marvel Studios
loves to release their TV spots and
their special looks and they'll even
release minute clips of the movies at
some points so unless it's a trailer
like Spider-Man no way home which Marvel
Studios has to work with Sony 4 there is
definitely a big possibility that we
could get at least footage for the
Marvels if not the full official trailer
we've gotten the teaser so far but the
full trailer will tell us more about the
actual story that is happening in the
Marvels because of course it's going to
be more than just they use their powers
and switch places with each other and
they might show some secret Invasion
footage since it's right around the
corner they might not focus on it too
much but if we are getting footage for
anything else it is definitely going to
be for secret Invasion however I will
say if they do decide to do Agatha coven
of Chaos in 2023 which I don't think so
at this point because it's pretty packed
for Marvel already they could show us
some footage for that we know they've
been filming for a while now but if it's
early 2024 maybe we could get a brief
clip of Agatha cing up chaos and I would
love that I would love to see not only
Agatha but Aubrey Plaza's character as
well because I'm really looking forward
to her performance and on top of that as
we talked about before Marvel Studios
might kind of be shuffling around their
Phase 5 and Phase 6 schedule right now a
lot of these Phase 5 projects don't have
official release dates yet so hopefully
Marvel Studios can give us an actual
schedule to all of these projects that
they've already announced and of of
course hopefully they will reveal to us
the entirety of Phase 6 we already know
four major movies that are coming in
Phase 6 Deadpool the Fantastic 4 Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars hopefully they
fill in the blanks of the rest of the
Phase 6 lineup and if you have any idea
or just want to take a guess of what
those projects could be be sure to let
us know your thoughts and theories in
the comments down below and don't forget
about our giveaway if you subscribe to
the channel and leave a comment you're
entered in our giveaway away for a
chance to win an Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and today is the last day of the month
for this month's giveaway we'll start
next month again but today is the last
day for May so be sure to subscribe and
leave a comment down below we're also on
patreon now if you want to support the
channel we also have a website which we
post to several times a day and a
Discord server which will all link down
below you can also follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
B